first with both Joe Biden and Kamala
Harris preoccupied in Europe celebrating
an endless war just who's running the
show back here at home it is definitely
not pothole Pete Buddha judge now
America's incompetent Transportation
secretary he has been utterly M.I.A and
in just two years he aimlessly is
presided over multiple Airline fiascos
chaos at America's shipping ports a
supply chain nightmare that is still
ongoing and now a disaster in East
Palestine Ohio a train wreck followed by
a controlled chemical burn that released
all these dangerous chemicals into the
air the soil the water we have dead fish
dead animals sick people but pothole
Pete he's nowhere to be found same with
Joe and for Daisy has said nothing did
nothing about a toxic fire so huge that
it could be seen on Pittsburgh's weather
radar now ultimately pothole Pete he was
shamed into making a statement last week
he declared that East Palestine was
getting more than enough attention you
decide
while this horrible situation has gotten
a particularly high amount of attention
there are roughly 1 000 cases a year of
a train derailing obviously they have
levels of severity but where all of that
points us to is a need to continue to
raise the bar on rail savings oh really
that's the answer Pete train wrecks
followed by Massive chemical burns that
kill off local fish and wildlife that's
just an average day Creeks streams
filled with toxic substances that can be
seen by the naked eye if pothole Peach
seems lazy and out of touch to all of
you that is because it's true you know
recently he demanded Americans trust him
simply because he was once the mayor of
South Bend Indiana where he quote dealt
with a lot of disasters that's what he
said take a look
Administration has come under some fire
for its response to the mayor of East
Palestine has said it took nearly two
weeks for the White House to contact him
there were shouts of where's Pete Buddha
judge at a town hall meeting last week
what's your response to that when are
you going to go to East Palestine
well I am planning to go and our folks
were on the ground from the first hours
I do want to stress that the NTSB needs
to be able to do its work independently
but when I go the focus is going to be
on action look I was mayor of my
hometown for eight years we dealt with a
lot of disasters natural and human
a lot of disasters okay so we did a
little digging and found some of those
so-called disasters that uh pothole Pete
was forced to manage as mayor according
to the South Bend Tribune one of his
greatest challenges was turning several
one-way streets into two-way streets
that's a big challenge another major
challenge for pothole Pete the mayor
well he had to figure out what to do
with all of his City's empty lots and
last but not least his nickname pothole
Pete well he asked it for a reason
because under his leadership South Bend
Indiana was home to the worst roads in
the entire state or as political put it
quote the former mayor of a town with an
18 route bus system and giant pothole
problem will now have to Shepherd
Biden's National infrastructure plan in
other words mayor Pete is in way over
his head he was from day one now of
course Buddha judge still hasn't
bothered to visit East Palestine he says
he'll go when the 12 vote time is right
now of course the only reason Pete is
even considering a visit is because
former president Donald Trump he's going
to be there tomorrow and meanwhile Joe
Biden will probably never visit you know
he doesn't seem to care what's happening
in Ohio and if it's not in Delaware why
bother after all the people of Ukraine
they seem to be his number one priority
now listen to the mayor of East
Palestine when he heard Joe Biden was in
Ukraine with President zielinski take a
look
that was the biggest slap in the face
that tells you right now he doesn't care
about us so agreed he can send every
agency he wants to but uh I found that
out this morning in one of the briefings
that he was in the Ukraine giving
millions of dollars away to people over
there not to us and I'm furious on
President's Day in our country yeah
President's Day in our country he's he's
a over Ukraine so that tells you what
kind of guy he is
now Biden is still in Europe tonight and
not East Palestine hey Sean Hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else